The first way that we will
construct evolutionary trees is
by using a distance matrix.
And one of the most common ways of
constructing such a matrix is to begin
with a multiple alignment.
Here is a toy multiple alignment
that we'll use throughout this talk.
We can form a distance matrix from this
multiple alignment in which D sub i,j
is simply the number of differing
symbols between the i-th and
j-th rows of the multiple alignment.
i.e., there are three mismatches
between the first and second rows.
So we simply set D sub i,2 and D sub 2,1
of this distance matrix equal to 3.
Of course, we have encountered several
other different notions of distance
already that we could also use
to construct a distance matrix.
But constructing a distance matrix from
a multiple alignment is very common.
In order to construct a multiple
alignment of coronaviruses,
researchers chose the spike protein,
which identifies and
binds to receptor sites on
the host's cell membrane.
Here is the spike protein for
the SARS coronavirus.
You may have noticed that evolutionary
trees take the shape of a graph.
So we'll define a tree as a connected,
acyclic graph.
Because the tree is connected, it means
that it holds the tree in one piece.
And because it's acyclic,
it means that the tree can branch out
without growing back in on itself and
forming a cycle.
When we use a tree to model a phylogeny,
the present day species should be
at the ending nodes of the tree.
More formally, these ending nodes are
called "leaves", which I've shown in dark in
this tree of life and
they're simply nodes that have degree one.
The remaining nodes, shown in a lighter
color, are called "internal nodes", and
they're simply nodes of
a larger degree than one.
Now, trees come in all different shapes and
sizes, but the fact that they
are connected in a cyclic by definition
leads to some common properties.
For example, we can always find two
leaves in a tree as long as the tree
has at least two nodes, of course.
Also, a tree with n nodes
has exactly n - 1 edges.
For example,
the tree on the left has 14 nodes.
So regardless of what shape the tree
has or how it's nodes are connected,
we know that it must have 13 edges.
In order to model the most common
ancestor of all the species in trees,
we will sometimes place a "root" in a tree.
If a tree is rooted, shown here by
the green node, then the root can be
drawn at the top of tree with
the leaves at the bottom of the tree.
By reorienting the tree in this way,
we know that time flows
downward from the root to the leaves
in the sense that each edge
of the tree connects an older
species to a more recent species.
For now though, let's assume that
we are working with unrooted trees.
This leads us to a computational
problem of finding the tree
that "fits" a distance matrix.
Of course, I should have known that
Son would somehow show up today.
The problem that he has is
that we have been careless and
we haven't defined what we mean for
a tree to "fit" a distance matrix.
If we come back to the toy distance
matrix that we had for four species,
then I will go ahead and
show you a tree that fits it.
Here it is.
We will need to assign weights
to the edges of this tree so
that the sum of weights along
a path that connects two leaves
corresponds to the distance matrix
value for those two leaves.
Here we have weights of 1 and 2 and
they combine to give us a distance
of 3 between chimp and human.
The distance between chimp and
seal is 6, and
edge weights 1, 3, and
2 give us 6, and so on.
So you can verify that each
possible path through this tree,
if you add up the weights of
the edges along the path,
that gives you the distance matrix value.
Now we will use lower case d to indicate
the distance between leaves and a tree.
If you're given a tree
whose edges are weighted,
then it's a pretty straightforward
problem to just compute the distances
between each pair of leaves in that tree.
Of course, what we really want to
do is solve the reverse problem,
which is finding a tree whose distance
between leaves fits a given matrix.
You think this is now well defined?
If you're not sure what I'm
driving at with this question,
feel free to pause and
take moment to try this exercise.
Regardless of how long you spend
on this exercise that I gave you,
you will never find a tree fitting it,
because such a tree simply does not exist.
For this reason, we need to distinguish
between distance matrices that have trees
fitting them and distance matrices
that don't have trees fitting them.
A matrix that does have a tree
fitting it is called "additive".
There is another problem though,
which is that an additive matrix
could have more than one
tree fitting it, and it will.
Here's the tree we had before
fitting the toy distance matrix,
but we can simply stretch out
the edges into longer paths and
still have a tree that
fits the distance matrix.
But I would say that when
you look at these two trees,
the top one just seems nicer,
right?
Of course, we need to rigorously
define what we mean by "nicer".
The bottom tree has two
nodes of degree 2.
So we can get the graph on the top
from the graph on the bottom by
simply compressing all paths
that contain degree 2 nodes.
This leads us to define a simple tree,
as a tree that has no nodes
of degree 2, and the good news
is that if a matrix is additive,
i.e., there is a tree fitting
this distance matrix,
then there exists exactly one
simple tree that fits it.
Now that we're armed with some
better terminology, we can return to
the Distance-Based Phylogeny Problem that
we had before and restate it as finding
the simple tree that fits a given distance
matrix, as long as that matrix is additive.